[Musique]
blague à 17 heures oui un petit peu dur
allianz a vu début c'était dur les
parents moquer mais maintenant ça va
mieux
déjà un mois que tout a changé loin de
leurs familles guillaumin et silver ont
démarré ici une nouvelle étape de leur
vie celle qui doit les mener au haut
niveau
une vie bien remplie apprendre en cours
ont fini à midi on me dit on mange
après vers 14h15 heure ça détend d'un on
va à la gym et on irait jusqu'à 19h
19h15 viser l'excellence quand on est
pensionnaire du creps
il faut aussi brillé en classe avec un
petit avantage sur les autres élèves
la scolarité est aménagé priorité aux
seules matières fondamentales et cours
uniquement le matin sauf qu'avant
l'entraînement il y a aussi les devoirs
question doit poser comme calcul à
calcul il ya des chiffres qu'il ya des
signes d'opération et pour les plus
jeunes c'est gaël qui s'en chargent
exercices à faire car né à signer emploi
du temps un respect des différences
elle veille sur ses athlètes tout au
long de leur adolescence au creps on
remplace un petit peu la famille on les
prend au travail individualisé pour
pouvoir optimiser justement le les
apprentissages et la répétition pour que
scolairement ils soient au mieux de ce
qu'ils peuvent produire
sur cellules à turin bien dans ta table
c'est bien par contre c'est l'état peut
sauter du haut de ses 11 ans silver
enchaîne 22 heures d'entraînement par
semaine contre 8 l'an dernier dans son
club préparation physique travail des
alignements souplesse ici on va
développer ses capacités et corriger ses
défauts on travaille sur plusieurs
années rythmées par la compétition
moments préférés du gie mal un objectif
à toi c'est quoi
c'est à l'aide aux jeux olympiques est
de les gagner
un cas l'année 2004 comme lui ils sont
onze à rêver d'or olympique et de
collectifs france certains même déjà
titré dans leur catégorie d'âge les
objectifs qu'ils atteindront au prix
d'énormes sacrifices ils sont jamais
pouvoir vivre de leur passion
on leur vend pas du rêve on leur vend la
vérité que ça va être dur de tous les
jours c'est à se lever procès gyms
manger france et gym aller en cours et
penser quand même la gym c'est compliqué
on pleure on a mal on mais on oublie
souvent tout ça le jour où ça veut bien
rigolé en coupe est le jour on est sur
un podium généralement voilà le sens on
serre la main on est reparti pour un an
et tout le monde regarde ici on est
dangereux de son parcours
[Musique]